la commune a ressorti sa licence iv
garder bien au chaud durant 20 ans
histoire de recréer du lien social
mais le bistrot des options n'est pas
implantée à l'ancienne près de l'église
un peu excentré il est intégré au
nouveau pôle sportif et culturel donc
entrée principale qui donne accès donc
sur la salle de restaurant avec une
capacité de 32 personnes
ensuite on a la partie bistrot qui est
très sympathique dans lequel je souhaite
absolument que les gens se rencontrent
autour d'un vin local d'un produit local
le café le matin côté sympathique pour
bien démarrer une journée reste la
cuisine avec une pratique de plus de 20
ans et un savoir faire familial pour des
plats élaborés à partir de produits
locaux
l'histoire est belle mais le pari
n'est-il pas risqué on a cet
environnement justement qui est très
positif puisque on est quand même à côté
des bois on est au milieu d'un pôle
sportif on a du parking pour la
municipalité cette nouvelle dynamique va
bien au delà du pôle sportif et culturel
il faut comprendre qu'il n'est pas loin
aussi de tout l'aménagement qui était
fait autour de la gare tgv
cette zone d'activités que le bâtiment
signale avec d'autres bâtiments qui vont
voir le jour
donc ça viendra aussi appuyé avant
l'arrivée d'autres restaurants je pense
ou chaîne hôtelière par la suite ça
viendra aussi conforter aussi les
premières entreprises qui ont pris le
risque de venir s'implanter sur la gare
tgv
autour de ce pôle le bistrot des options
a mis la convivialité sur les rails
grande vitesse est temps de pause
embarqué dans un même élan
l'avenir le dira